[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport
l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département c'est parti
à pour le sommaire football ont joué ce
week-end les quarts de finale de la
coupe des yvelines plaisir s'est imposé
contre ball sur son terrain sur le score
de 3 buts à 1 dans une ambiance
électrique
le résumé du match est à suivre dans
quelques instants découverte la ville de
but qui a accueilli le premier tournoi
de floorball de l'histoire du
département des yvelines coup de
projecteur dans ce magazine sur ce sport
collectif qui ressemble au hockey sur
glace sans les patins et sans contact
violent automobile le circuit
jean-pierre beltoise accueillera le 4
mars prochain un stage pour les enfants
sur sa piste
les jeunes de 7 à 18 ans pour piloter
des voitures d'exception accompagnés de
moniteurs diplômés
plus de détails dans quelques instants
coup de projecteur à présent sur les
principaux résultats à sportifs du week
end
[Musique]
on commence donc ce magazine par l'une
des actualités les plus chaudes de ce
week-end les quarts de finale de coupe
des yvelines qui se sont déroulées à ce
dimanche les plaisirs recevez maul dans
son stade bernard giroux et les plaisirs
en ont réussi à valider leur ticket pour
le tour suivant grâce à une victoire 3
buts à 1 le résumé du match
un montage 220 fontanilles match des
grands jours ce dimanche le 18 février à
plaisir le club local affrontements pour
une place en demi-finale de la coupe des
yvelines équilibrée sur les 45 premières
minutes le match des blocs juste avant
la mi-temps après ce but inscrit par
l'attaquant kevin l'orphelin c'était dur
on l'appelle boucle gaz on appelle eu
beaucoup d'occasions mais le plus
importante à sion c'est d'avoir mis le
but 1-0 pourrait être obligé de se
découvrir et je pense que c'est là qu'on
est les meilleurs
une fin de première période idéale sur
laquelle l'entraîneur plaisir roy s'est
appuyé pour construire son discours à la
mi-temps ne pas s'énerver poser le
ballon et jouer surtout voilà c'est
vraiment notre qualité sur laquelle on
s'appuie sur de plus les milanais donc
et puis je pense qu'ils sont un peu
stressés donc vraiment détendre tout ça
rend message non reçus par les joueurs
les plaisirs wa nerveux ne parviennent
pas à ressortir le ballon et commet de
nombreuses fautes
sanction immédiate moon revient à
égalité après dix minutes de jeu en
seconde période
un avantage de courte durée plaisir
reprend la main sur penalty
après ce but la tension change de camp
les joueurs de maule durcissent le jeu
plaisir à l'occasion de tuer le match à
plusieurs reprises la libération viendra
finalement dans les arrêts de jeu le
héros du jour mamadou syma qu'on s'offre
un doublé sur penalty de penalty
c'est la chance on va dire ça c'est
rentré c'est rentré et voilà tout c'est
un joueur que je revenais au club ya
trois ans et qui cette année
marchi soit très bien enfin on peut pas
obtenir une prestation que d'un joueur
je pense que c'est l'ensemble de
l'équipe qui a été très très bonne donc
fait le boulot c'était difficile match
un match assez compliqué on le savait
face à une belle équipe de maule très
très beau match plaisant et on a réussi
à gagner donc c'est important d'aller
l'aller en demi-finale en demi-finale
plaisir affrontera mort pas une équipe
qui évolue en d1 de district
une division au dessus des plaisirs oit
la rencontre se disputera le dimanche
1er avril dans le chaudron du stade
bernard giraud dans les autres matches
de ces quarts de finale de coupe des
civils maurepas s'est imposé dans la
douleur aux tirs au but 5 à 4 après
avoir concédé le nul sur son terrain
contre l'équipe des mureaux de son côté
guy en cours s'est facilement imposée à
l'extérieur sur le terrain de verneuil 3
à 0
et puis hardricourt s'est qualifié pour
le prochain tour en remportant son match
2 à 1 contre gargenville le tirage des
demi finales s'est déjà déroulé maurepas
se déplacera sur le terrain de plaisir
et guyancourt recevra hardricourt le
week-end du 25 mars
on continue à parler de la coupe des
yvelines avec nous en plateau pierre
guillemot lé vice président délégué du
district d i mean de football qui nous a
rejoints à l'instant bonsoir bonsoir
alors que pour ce goût de ces quarts de
finales qui se sont déroulées à ce week
end écoutez c'est un petit peu comme
tous les ans quoi ce sont des rencontres
disputées sont des rencontres à enjeu
donc bas pour les vainqueurs tant mieux
pour les vaincus il faudra recommencer
l'année prochaine voilà une certaine
tension sur le terrain de plaisir
notamment et c'est un peu des matches
comme ça quand il ya un enjeu il ya
forcément un petit peu de tension mais
bon je pense que tout s'est arrangé
après le match s'il ya des petites
choses à régler en fonction des des
critiques de certains ont l'air ivre a
tranquillement cette coupe 10 17 coupes
désigné c'est un vrai succès pour le
département c'est un succès oui depuis
des années que ça existe
les clubs sont friands de la coupe
comme dans tout le département ou la
ligue où même les professionnels
donc là il n'y a pas de professionnels
mais les les clubs adore cette
compétition parce que ça ça amène déjà
ça peut amener un titre et puis on
rencontre des équipes qu'on n'a pas
l'habitude dhabi de rencontrer en
championnat donc ça donne un piment
supplémentaire
les clubs jouent le jeu à fond vraiment
sur cette côte et je me mets de leur
équipe titulaire à chaque fois à oui
c'est pas comment professionnel on n'a
pas beaucoup de clubs doublette l'équipe
b lors d'un tour de coupe
tout le monde joue le jeu voulait
effectivement et on voit également
autour du terrain là il y avait encore
un plaisir plusieurs centaines de
spectateurs en 2016 lors d'un match
entre maurepas et du roi y avait
plusieurs milliers de spectateurs il y
avait eu quelques fumigènes notamment
aussi en tribunes sur le goût c'est
vraiment une réussite populaire aussi
cette coupe des yvelines oui bien sûr
parce que quand on arrive dans les
derniers tours comme c'était le cas ce
week-end avec les quarts de finale japp
le ppe-de équipes qui ont déjà passé
plusieurs tours et donc qui tiennent
vraiment
arrivé au bout et donc bah ça ça attire
du public en plus et c'est tant mieux
pour le football et c'est une
compétition vraiment importante pour le
district également d une belle
parenthèse cette coupe de france coupe
de paris
oui oui enfin la compétition la plus
importante c'est le championnat bien sûr
mais c'est la coupe des yvelines c'est
une compétition que tout le monde a à
coeur de remporter
alors on y met peut-être les moyens
aussi pour faire que cette coupe des
yvelines soit attractive il ya une
formule qui est étudié ou pas au niveau
de la fin du district pour créer une
nouvelle coupe des yvelines où on garde
une recette qui fonctionne pour
l'instant on regarde une recette qui
fonctionne parce qu'elle fonctionne bien
la preuve on avait quand même
une dizaine de catégories qui jouait je
n'avais pas que les seniors et les u 17
les u19 les cdm les vétérans et le
football du lundi soir qui va jouer ce
soir dans tout le monde
un petit peu toutes les catégories sont
en jeu jouera plus tard les quarts de
finale des féminines et puis des u15 qui
n'ont pas joué ce week-end puisque
c'était les vacances donc ça attire un
petit peu tout le monde et c'est
vraiment une compétition à part entière
et que les clubs apprécié un pronostic
sur ces demi finales qui se disputeront
en mars
duffy saisir contre maurepas et
guyancourt contraire des cours alors
on peut sans être vrai un vrai
pronostiqueurs on sait que nos repas et
au sommet de la d1 aujourd'hui mais
plaisir est au sommet de la d2
guyancourt est un petit peu en dessous
est pratiquement à égalité avec et je
crois à égalité avec hardricourt donc ça
sera sûrement deux matches très serrés
et j'espère que le meilleur l'emportera
tout simplement donc mort paf favori
pour cette coupe des yvelines seront un
petit peu parce qu'il ya une division
d'écart mais ça veut pas dire grand
chose en coupe on passe maintenant notre
deuxième thématique avec vous ce sont
les matchs qui ont été interrompues
suite aux crues suite à la neige suite
aux pluies diluviennes qu'on a pu avoir
au mois de janvier dans les yvelines
des dizaines de matches voire des
centaines de matchs ont été reportés
dans les yvelines
est ce qu'on pourra rejouer tous ses
matches alors il va falloir qu'on lire
jour par contre ça va exiger beaucoup
d'aménagements
on va certainement jouer pendant les
vacances scolaires on va jouer
certainement pendant les jours fériés
ce qui arrange pas tout le monde mais
malheureusement on a aujourd'hui 750
matchs qui sont à jouer puisque la
plupart ne se sont pas joués n'ont pas
été interrompus sont pas été disputé du
tout à cause de la neige à cause de la
pluie comme vous disiez et donc ça c'est
une problématique que notre commission
d'organisation des compétitions dont un
peu un casse tête en ce moment mais bon
on va réussir à leur salle exigera
peut-être des arrangements même entre
clubs quand ils s'entendront pour jouer
une date adéquate pour eux on leur
permettra de jouer à ces moments là
parce que les jours fériés ça perturbe
d'autant plus parce que quand on me
demande de jouer le 1er mai lui même
certaines municipalités ferme leur
terrain
donc les clubs ne peuvent pas profiter
des installations donc ça ça des effets
induits qui si tout le monde joue le jeu
c'est possible oui de recaser tous est
absolument pour finir le championnat
alors alors juste qu'il fallait
remporter tous ses matches ah oui quand
on joue enfin caen avec le niveau 2 de
paix soeur de neige qui avaient plus les
pluies comme vous parliez diluviennes
précédemment les terrain en pelouse
était injouable
et puis certains synthétique avec la
pelouse sont un peu les clubs sont un
peu craintif de jouer dessus puis
l'épaisseur était vraiment trop trop
grande
c'était pas possible de faire jouer
c'est votre choix et puis en plus quand
certains clubs ont la chance d'avoir un
synthétique basse ils ont trois quatre
matches dans la même journée il faudra
les jouer tous en même temps dont je il
ya quand même des faut faire des choix
et il ya des matches qui sont remis à ce
moment là est-ce qu'il faut que plus de
terrain synthétique
selon vous plaisir a pu jouer par
exemple ce week-end en coupe des
yvelines
oui sur son terrain synthétique et non
pas sur son terrain d'honneur ouais bel
avantage du synthétique c'est que mise à
part c'est cet épisode de neige
pratiquement tout le monde a joué
puisque on a remis conduit la neige en a
remis une journée complète qui coûte
quand même environ 225 matches une
journée complète en compétition 11
donc cette journée-là sera remise le
jour de passe je rappelle tout le monde
forcément parce qu'il ya des tournois
aussi pour les clubs essayent de
profiter des longs week-ends pour faire
des coûts des déplacements ou pour
organiser des tournois chez eux ça va
être compliqué mais on va y arriver dans
la question ce ne sera pas trop usant
pour les organismes des joueurs qu'il
faut les sportifs yvelinois sont en
pleine forme et voulant jouer tous les
trois jours
quasiment il y en a certains qui
joueront ce qu'ils ont beaucoup de
matches en retard il ya trois quatre
équipes et notamment trappe qui n'a pas
joué depuis la mi décembre sur son
terrain il y en a mais vous savez
l'année dernière on avait avec les
vacances scolaires les vacances
scolaires de fait 2 février était tout
au tout début février il ya eu des
intempéries en janvier y en a comme voir
jouer de descendre à début mars
merci à vous d'être passé sur ce plateau
je voudrais espère que la météo sera
beaucoup plus clémentes absolument les
prochains mois dans les yvelines un déni
un dernier résultat de football avant de
refermer cette page en nationale 3
verset n'a pu faire mieux que match nul
sur son terrain contre sénart-moissy ce
dimanche le score 2 buts partout au
classement versailles perd du terrain
sur les premiers les versets sont 4e
avec un point de retard sur le troisième
les gobelins et six points sur le leader
bobigny au rugby plaisir jouer à ce
week-end l'un de ses matches les plus
importants de sa saison dans le
championnat de fédérale 2 contre arras
et deux équipes sont toutes les deux en
course dans la lutte pour le maintien
les plaisirs wallon emporté 23 17 à
l'extérieur une bouffée d'oxygène au
classement plaisir est aux portes de la
zone de relégation la 10e place sur
douze engagés et compte désormais neuf
points d'avancé sur le premier relégable
art à son adversaire du jour prochain
match le dimanche 4 euros mars à
domicile contre rennes toujours en lui
mais cette fois ci dans le championnat
honneur versailles recevait sur son
terrain melun favori de cette rencontre
les faire les versaillais ont assumé
leur statut et s'impose facilement 26 à
7 une victoire qui permet aux joueurs de
la cité royale de conserver leur
troisième place au championnat avec un
bilan de 9 victoires pour trois défaites
depuis le début de la saison
handball féminin ont joué ce week-end
dans le championnat de nationale 2
montigny le bretonneux a concédé sa
neuvième défaite de la saison en 12
matches contre le paris saint-germain
lésigny montaigne se sont inclinés
tu es un vin dans leur gymnase malgré
les cinq buts de pauline bigot et les
quatre réalisations de la capitaine
clémence campagne au classement au
montigny le bretonneux reste lanterne
rouge du championnat avec 16 points
engrangés depuis le début de la saison
prochain match le 3 mars à l'hectare
contre l'équipe d'hazebrouck
je vous propose maintenant de vous
déhancher au rythme de la musique dans
ce set sports la coupe de france de
danse sportive était organisée ce samedi
17 février à versailles par le comité
des yvelines les meilleurs couples
français de la catégorie jeunes aux
seniors se sont produits devant
plusieurs centaines de spectateurs au
gymnase mont boron
au programme de la samba du tango du
paso doble et du cha cha cha et danseurs
ont tous été notée pour leurs
performances le juge international
france ducroix nous explique les
critères de sélection était au micro de
patrick jacques de dixmude
les juges ont évalué les coûts sur
plusieurs critères
on va dire que la danse est évalué dans
surtout dans trois domaines il ya un
domaine technique
un domaine artistique est un domaine
sportif le premier critère est le plus
important étant la musique qu'elle
respecte la rythmique de la musique
c'était une première dans les yvelines
at-on loi de floorball un sport dérivé
du hockey sur glace s'était organisé ce
week-end à buc qui comptait pour le
championnat de d3 coup de projecteur sur
ce sport encore confidentiel en montage
signé à jules grandes villes la folie du
floorball s'est emparé de buc ce samedi
17 et dimanche 18 février la ville a
accueilli le premier tournoi de cette
discipline organisée dans les yvelines
un sport à porter tout droit des pays
scandinaves
c'est comme vieux quai sur glace mais
sans printemps sans la patinoire comme
du hockey sur gazon mais à l'intérieur
bon du coup on est sur l'équivalent d'un
terrain de hand ball donc avec les mêmes
basket avec une crosse et
et on est au chaud ce jour là six
équipes se sont affrontées au gymnase du
prés saint jean dont l'équipe locale des
jets de but
sur le terrain les matchs durent trois
fois vingt minutes avec des pousses de
cinq minutes entre chaque tir tant en
cours ton temps des d'une part et
d'autre du terrain deux minutes par par
shift et puis ensuite on repart se
reposer un petit peu sur le banc avant
de rentrer il faut pas mal de cardio de
rapidité
donc il faut avoir un minimum en fait de
deux conditions sportives et en faisant
du corbeau du court la développe aussi
comme pour le hockey sur glace les
équipes sont composées de cinq joueurs
plus un gardien ce dernier reste tout le
match sur le terrain
un poste clé pour remporter la victoire
qu'elle était principal c'est d'avoir
beaucoup de réflexes aussi d'avoir de
l'anticipation pour voir d'où arrive la
balle qu'elle arrive de loin qu'elle
arrive de proches qu'elles arrivent par
un joueur un petit peu décalé
c'est le jeu aussi des adversaires de
cette boucher la vue du gardien est donc
vraiment beaucoup de réflexes d arrêt
réflexe des gardiens qui ont conquis le
public de buc et la folie du floorball
n'est pas près de s'arrêter
elle semble même se propager aux
nouvelles générations de la commune
[Musique]
l'équipe de floorball des jets de but
qu'a remporté ses deux matches du
week-end et se qualifie pour les playoff
les rencontres se dérouleront les 24 et
25 mars prochains
je vous propose à présent de partir sur
les parquets de basket l'endroit préféré
de michel allard un pionnier du club de
basket de trappes et de la verrière
la semaine dernière ils assistent aux
matchs de le sca trappe face au havre un
rêve qu'il souhaitait réaliser alors
qu'on son état de santé s'était dégradé
l'association manier coise éducatives et
culturelles organisé cette sortie
un reportage de nicolas nourris il n'a
pas pu s'en empêcher à près de 80 ans
michel allard a tenté quelques tirs au
panier
cet ancien joueur et dirigeant du club
de trappes la verrière est venu voir
jouer les seniors de nationale 3
l'occasion d'évoquer ses souvenirs
d'entraîneur
quelques photos peut-être que vous êtes
dessus et indique que je rappelle
qu'elle ouvrait sa carrière s'est rassis
rachid la caméra rachid
il nous a trahis de vinci
abboud et il a préféré depuis son avc en
2009 qui n'avait plus revu un match 2 le
fc trappes un manque pour ce passionné
qui a marqué ses premiers paniers à
l'âge de 8 ans sacré ma famille ma
famille à ma quand la rencontre débute
michel allard n'hésite pas à commenter
les actions son passé d'entraîneur
ressurgi sur le bord du terrain
c'est trop longtemps je trouve que
chaque robot 21 contre attaque l'hérault
sur le banc de touche à ses côtés
l'association manic oise éducatives et
culturelles a organisé cette sortie et
surtout sa petite fille alexandra ça me
fait très plaisir surtout que ces voix
là c'est quelque chose qu'ils voulaient
faire du kart un moment donc moi ça ne
me plaisait de l'accompagner ce soir
pour ce beau match en fait quand j'étais
plus jeune
la compagnie a cessé match de basket je
regardais donc j'ai toujours baigné
dedans accompagner les seniors dans
leurs rêves et leurs envies par
l'intermédiaire de
deux jeunes adultes de l'adolescent de
la commune de magny ou autres lors de
cette rencontre trappe s'inclinent
finalement sur le score de 64 à 88 face
au havre et le passionné dresse son
bilan par rapport à cette défaite est sa
grande gueule il est resté le même
personnage à savoir à très impliqué pas
toujours modérée dans ses appréciations
qui reviennent la prochaine fois et en
fera lyon fra lyon gagnera au moins et
michel allard compte revenir pour une
prochaine rencontre de le fc trappes
avec l'espoir d'assister cette fois ci à
une victoire de son club
des images insolites à présent après
avoir accueilli un match de handball
féminin début février le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines s'est
transformée en un gigantesque circuit
souvent dans l'histoire pour la 8e
édition de la butte âge parti pour cette
première en ile-de-france 250 têtes
poulet se sont affrontés avec des mini
motos sur un tracé improvisé avec des
barrières et une rampe de plusieurs
mètres de haut
ce soir là pas de classement mais une
bonne dose de ré entre avec ses fans de
jackie stewart ou steve mcqueen on
écoute les réactions micro de grégory
canale qui avait adopté la nuque longue
pour l'occasion et on est tous des
sportifs de sports extrêmes
donc on gère notre manière les risques y
a pas vraiment beaucoup de risques parce
que la piste va pas très vite et tout ça
donc on essaye de canaliser les gens
dans un bordel la vitesse du plaisir
y'a pas l'esprit de compétition c'est
juste le daily record c'est super bonne
ambiance il ya beaucoup de sorties va
débattre on fait des courses son tour
des plots des champs de bosses de bmx
est vraiment on prend le taux d'enfants
qu'on équipe avec des choses pour a dû
mais on sait quand on passe maintenant
notre rubrique agenda
[Musique]
on continue à parler de sport automobile
dans cette émission ce dimanche 4 mars
le circuit jean-pierre beltoise en
partenariat avec l'école de pilotage
formula keynes invite les enfants à
conduire sur des voitures d'exception
pendant un stage
l'événement est destiné aux 7 à 18 ans
il est encadré par des professionnels
dont les pilotes professionnels
anthony à beltoise et mike parisy il a
quand même terminé à 6e en 24 heures du
mans en 2015 sur porsche cyclisme sur
piste à présent la sélection française
pour les championnats du monde a été a
dévoilé au début du mois de début du
mois au vélotour national de saint
quentin en yvelines
les coaches ont décidé de retenir à des
têtes d'affiché comme quentin lafargue
mathilde de gros et bien sûr ligne
montrent un à françois pervis pour
participer à cette compétition du 28
février au 4 mars
on retrouve également le plaisir ou à
michael d'almeida qui réintègre l'équipe
de france après avoir été écarté pendant
un an et demi de ses équipes de france à
suite aux jo de 2016 nous avons pu le
rencontrer à mes côtés et michael
d'almeida la sélection française pour
les championnats du monde au pays bien
vient tout juste de tomber
michael d'almeida vous êtes dans
l'équipe vous réintégrer cette équipe
est ce que ça vous fait plaisir
première question plaisir oui bien
entendu c'est toujours une satisfaction
d'être d'être sélectionné en équipe de
france donc
donc voila depuis depuis ma dernière
sélection entre guillemets aux jeux
olympiques qui s'est conclue par une
médaille de bronze tout de même
j'avais levé un peu le pied et puis
voilà me voilà de retour aux affaires
comme il faut c'était déjà dans les
cartons on peut le dire vous avez été
réintégré par l'équipe de france il ya
quelques semaines vous avez participé
des manches de coupe du monde également
est-ce que c'était prévisible cette
sélection elle était prévisible bien
entendu après moi ce n'était pas un
objectif que je m'étais fixé j'ai
derrière moi que quatre mois
d'entraînement le point d'interrogation
et sk en quatre mois
enfin de quoi je serais capable en
quatre mois oui j'ai participé à une
coupe du monde il ya trois semaines
c'est encore une fois une sélection que
j'ai gagné c'était pas c'était pas un
acquis donc j'ai eu l'opportunité
d'aller m'exprime en coupe du monde et
lors de cette coupe du monde va en en
réalisant les meilleurs temps personnels
à mon poste en vitesse par équipes
bon ben voila j'ai j'ai gagné ma
sélection maintenant pour les
championnats du monde qui seront à la
fin du mois la vitesse par équipes
ça sera votre épreuve phare du coût de
ces championnats du monde vous allez
partager cette vitesse par équipe avec
françois pervis également sébastien
vigier un cycliste on peut le dire
expérimenté un autre un peu moins
expérimenté qui a acquis à 20 ans est ce
que c'est le bon compromis finalement le
bon compromis
c'est d'avoir des athlètes qui vont vite
voilà pour moi pour moi l'expérience
l'expérience est quelque chose qui
s'obtient avec avec les années avec la
pratique
sébastien vigier a quand même pratique
et beaucoup de vitesse par équipes
d'ailleurs de très belle manière très
honorable donc voilà pour moi c'est pour
moi c'est quelqu'un qui a déjà de
l'expérience qui va en avoir encore j'en
aurai moi aussi encore lors de lors de
ces championnats et puis on peut prendre
le contre exemple de françois qui est
plus vieux que moi et qui pourtant n'a
pas fait beaucoup de championnats du
monde en vitesse par équipes a aussi
paradoxalement que ça puisse paraître
donc voilà l'expérience l'expérience et
c'est pas une question d'âge c'est une
question de pratique et on en acquiert
tout au long de sa carrière justement
avec des expériences comme çà de là vous
pensez que vous serez et favori de ces
championnats du monde
je l'espère j'en sais trop rien pour
l'instant c'est difficile pour moi pour
moi de me prononcer je suis quelqu'un
d'assez pragmatique et ambitieux donc
voila moi mon ambition bien entendu
c'est qu'on soit les meilleurs
maintenant voilà est-ce qu'on est les
favoris
je sais pas c'est pas à moi de le dire
par contre je pense que on en fait
partie
faut pas se le cacher
l'équipe de france ne doit pas viser
autre chose qu'une médaille maintenant
voilà la couleur de la médaille on verra
contre qui on luttera justement je pense
que dès les qualifications on verra ça
me permettra un mois de jauger voilà le
niveau global de notre équipe de d'avoir
un état aussi de des autres équipes et
puis voilà à partir de là à part à
partir des qualifications je pense qu'on
pourra établir directement parce qu'on
joue le titre ou les entraînements déjà
commencé avec vous trois là avec nous
trois oui oui bien entendu les
entraînements ont déjà commencé après il
n'y a pas à pas non plus en pratique et
plus qu'il n'en faut on se connaît on
fait du vélo ensemble tous les jours
voilà ce qui ce qui compte c'est juste
prendre quelques petits repères mais
encore une fois les repères c'est comme
l'expérience s'acquiert lors des
compétitions
donc voilà on fait ce qu'on sait faire
on se parle entre nous on s'explique un
peu comment chacun envoie les choses et
puis voilà après on fera parler la
poudre sur la piste et ce qui compte
après c'est s'exprimer et sa voix voilà
montrer ce qu'on a dans les jambes et
sortir un chrono puis le reste le reste
a su de votre côté ce qu'il ya de
l'appréhension
non non non il n'y a pas d'appréhension
du tout il ya au contraire de
l'excitation
l'appréhension elle était plutôt il ya
quelques semaines en arrière quand j'ai
quand j'ai été sélectionné pour la
manche de coupe du monde à minsk voilà
là j'avais un petit peu d'appréhension
de de savoir où j'en étais moins à titre
personnel avec seulement quatre mois
d'entraînement dans les jambes et bon
ben j'ai pu me rassurer aussi entre
guillemets en voyant que je faisais
toujours partie des meilleurs mondiaux
et que j'avais même battu mon record
personnel donc non il ya strictement
aucune appréhension au contraire moi les
championnats du monde et jeux olympiques
cdc des compétitions qui galvanise donc
enclenché je suis prêt et excité
dernière question vous aviez remporté
une médaille d'or aux championnats du
monde ici à saint quentin en yvelines
sur cette piste qui est juste derrière
nous est-ce que vous allez remporter une
dans quelques semaines bien sûr je vais
pour ça et puis bah pour l'anecdote à
apeldoorn c'est là où j'ai obtenu mon
premier titre de champion du monde aussi
en 2011 donc voilà c'est pas c'est pas
une piste on va pas dans l'inconnu j'ai
été champion du monde là bas aussi j'ai
été champion du monde ici à saint
quentin
alors maintenant à chaque fois que je
saute je sors de toute façon c'est pour
donner le meilleur de moi même et si le
meilleur de moi-même c'est d'être
champion du monde voilà je m'en prive
pas je prends donc donc voilà maintenant
maintenant il faut se concentrer encore
sur l'entraînement qui reste à accomplir
d'aujourd'hui à aux championnats du
monde et puis et puis voilà d'edel 28
jeu fera parler la poudre
merci michael d'almeida les championnats
du monde aux pays-bas c'est du 28
février au 4 mars
c'est la fin de son set 8 sport très
belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]